[Music]
here we go again
sony have revealed the games will
receive as ps plus subscribers for the
month of august 2021.
you can get your digital hands on these
from the first tuesday of the month
which is august the 3rd this time around
first up is plant vs zombies battle for
naberville which has come an awful long
way from the tower defense game we used
to play on iphone
this plants vs zombies is a third person
shooter in both competitive and
cooperative modes
turf takeover is arguably the standout
mode in which two teams of 12
fight for supremacy the round ends
following a final objective
such as delivering bombs to the enemy
base whilst avoiding marshmallow meteors
the battle arena is worth your time too
with your team of four sent up against
another without any respawns
things can become a little more tactical
here as you find the right classes to
complement each other's play style
by the way there are four key classes
attackers defenders
supporters and swarm plants vs zombies
battle for neighborville
has you running around as a zombie
superhero and a sunflower
if that's your kind of weird be sure to
pick it up in august
game number two is tennis world tour 2.
i'll be honest right away i'm going to
struggle to make this sound desirable
mainly due to the card system which
gives your player boosts and effects
in an unrealistic fashion for a
simulation game if you've ever wanted to
create your own player and take them
through the ranks and win one of the
mages like the french open
world tour may be the game for you the
career mode is both challenging and
rewarding as you master your shot
choices against world class opposition
tennis world tour 2 released only 10
months ago making this an extremely
recent game
sadly the review scores tell us this is
only a 5 out of 10 outing
so go in with low expectations and you
should be okay but hey just because i
don't recommend it and the major
reviewers don't like it
doesn't mean you won't love it i really
hope somebody does and finally a game i
told you about earlier this month
hunter's arena legends there was a
little confusion if this would release
on ps5
only but the pr team confirmed this is
on ps plus
on both ps4 and ps5 there are two core
game modes available
good old battle royale and a new
one-on-one fighting arena tag match
unlike pretty much every other vr game
you've played before
hunter's arena is melee focused the
combat may look hack and slash
but in fact there's more to it than that
it's more like soul calibur if you ever
played that
the combat system promotes combos and
juggling
blocking your foes attacks before
unleashing your own knocking them out of
the ring
or depleting their health to get the win
this fighting system continues into
battle royale with highly technical
duels
which could and will be third parted by
opportunists
as battle royale fights can be few and
far between with real players
the game also offers in-world bosses to
flesh out the action
taking down one of these ai controlled
guys will result in
improved loot and stats ready for the
elusive final battle
for the epic victory so that's august on
ps plus what you're thinking
you happy sad delighted mad let me know
your thoughts i'm adam you're awesome
thanks for sticking around till the end
i'll see you next time